let me start by showing you this article
and i do this
uh with with these articles specifically
because
i want to make sure everybody realizes
we're not just pulling these things
you know out of thin air these are
conversations that actually happen these
are articles that actually exist and
these are ideas that we did not come up
with
business insider says a book published
nearly 25 years ago predicted america
would hit a great crisis
climaxing around 2020 and then up next
is a millennial versus boomer standoff
that will
usher in a new world order they say
america sees a turning
every 20 years as one generation
displaces another
and the dynamic between one particular
generation entering elderhood
and another entering young adulthood
creates a crisis every 80 years
according to a theory prophesied in neil
howe and william strasse's the fourth
turning
the authors wrote the next crisis era
would start around 2005
and climax around 2020 and would involve
millennials and boomers fighting over
the shape of the world to come
there are some similarities between
recent events and the book's predictions
the 2008 financial crisis can be seen as
the catalyst they mentioned
and in 2020 and in early 2021 unrest has
shaken the economy
politics it says the economy twice and
the economy okay
it's unclear whether the fourth turning
is how and stross characterize it is
really happening right now
but the parallels are certainly
eye-catching there's also some other
uh there's other other theories there's
also thucydides trap
which suggests that whenever an economic
power is about to displace the principal
superpower
war breaks out in the past 16 major
instances
12 times there has been very serious war
many fear that we are now entering this
period with china
i guess the bigger question is if these
academics predicted this
was going to be the fourth turning and
we are going to enter in some
catastrophic period
if people can see thucydides trap are
there efforts to prevent it
and before we open it go into like the
bigger discussion i'll just point out
uh they say that the last 80-year period
start
and i guess it started just after world
war ii right
actually why don't you explain like what
this means well the whole thing
you know so the fourth turning is the
fourth season that's the winter
crisis and you know so they call it a
ceculum which means a long life
um this goes actually all the way back
to the etruscan
prior to the romans but it starts let's
just say it starts in the
spring with a high um and then it goes
into an awakening
which would be the summer and then the
fall is called the unraveling and then
the winter
is the crisis period and it keeps
turning i heard a really good guy
actually interviewing
um neil howe i think it was and he said
like you know if history
doesn't repeat it surely rhymes because
every single time these crisis periods
come back around
they're not exactly the same but they
resemble each other and
there's core tenets to them that
resemble one another
and um and yeah they surely said like
the the
book came out in 97. they said somewhere
around 2005
give or take a couple years there's
going to be an inciting incident
and if it comes later it'll probably
come at around 2008
right when two-thirds of the boomer
generation i think it was would
uh be eligible for their social social
security so that was the housing
uh collapse right there and that would
be an economic
inciting incident that would lead into
and i wrote some things down we can get
to it later but
they in chapter six of the book the
fourth turning
there's eerie like very eerie kinds of
predictions that go
right into what you could call now the
winter period the crisis period
and then game of thrones they were like
winter is coming yeah long winter
but about but does that mean we're
through the worst of it we're we're on
our way out towards this
you know beautiful utopian springtime
it's very interesting because like they
uh in the book they said
it will it won't be any shorter than 15
years it won't be any longer than 20
years if
history repeats in the same way it's
never gone any longer than 20 years so
after because i think neil howe works in
dc
now and he advises people and he said
somewhere around 2028
it should be concluded and that's when
the high the next high will start
and if you think about it like the the
crisis is like a crunching period and
anytime you come out of a crunch it
feels like a high
there's a big restructuring so uh i've
heard 2025 is the year to look at
so then when did the first the last
spring time start
last spring time would have been man
um 1945 after 1945 i mean that that
seemed like a pretty definitive end
to the crisis period that means the
crisis period
reached its end with mass bloodshed and
76 million dead
when yeah yeah when was the new deal
because apparently that was
they also mentioned that in the book the
new deal because they
they don't just talk about like war but
for some reason when you go back
80 to 90 years you look at world war ii
great depression 80 to 90 years before
that
give or take some civil war before that
the the last winter was the revolution
before that because they're talking
mainly anglo-saxon history
uh the glorious revolution in england
and so it it
lines up when you look at it definitely
lines up there's other authors who
popped onto
1933 new deal yeah okay and the glorious
revolution england was like when they
made prince or king john
sign the magna carta is that what that
was was that it
was sometime in the 1600s i think oh
that was 1200 okay never mind
four turnings before yeah yeah um i've
noticed that in 2028 this year you're
saying might be
the new awake or not the awakening but
the uh the high the high
is when graphene is purported to become
peak which means that society has
completely
in in inundated itself with graphene
like we're
instead of using steel we're now using
graphene for buildings touch screens
battery power
electricity all that interesting yeah
there's a lot of predictions elon musk
says 2023
we should be able to expect um super
intelligent ai
i mean these are all you know
speculations do you want me to just read
just like two paragraphs of what they
predicted would happen in this
period yeah okay so they said around
2005
a financial event will likely spark the
the coming crisis
a succession will be spoken of uh our
succession will be spoken of heavily
secession i'm sorry secession like
seceding states seceding in the union
say and they said it could be something
having to do with like taxes and irs
what was it they said that was going to
happen in 2005 no no
they said starting starting in 2005. so
they're saying there will be a financial
event is usually what sparks these
things
and then after that they're talking
about during the entire crisis period
you'll
see these things come up so secession
will be spoken of heavily
a potential terrorist group may blow up
an aircraft and claim to have portable
weapons of mass destruction or nuclear
weapons
the us will um potentially strike
um the responsible country preemptively
i don't know what that means because the
you know they they already attacked
they already attacked um some will blame
the president for con
concocting the attack for political
purposes militia groups will rise up
against um
urban gangs uh cyber attacks
cdc may announce the spread of a new
communicable
uh virus this is all in chapter six wow
i'm not making this up what is happening
you know uh a new communicable virus
that will reach densely
populated areas and kill some uh i'm
trying to use as many verbatim words as
i can
mandatory quarantine will happen
president
uh will order national guard into major
cities
again urban gangs battling suburban
militias
and calls mount for the president to
declare martial law
insurrection will
i i i know they said that uh several
times in chapter six i just didn't get
the exact
sentence but they mentioned insurrection
several times and
all events will escalate they're like
every
the inciting incident will set off a
chain reaction of other events
and until the climax there will be
nothing that brings down the intensity
like world war ii when world war ii
officially ended boom springtime next
so that means 2027 is gonna be
brutal gonna be absolutely chaos i mean
the theory is maybe it was 911 that
sparked this
and that was the the aircraft thing that
they actually mentioned
this is the brutal ending too oh and
they wrote when they wrote this when in
1997
it was published in 97 which means i
think they started writing it in 88 with
a different idea
so wait wait wait wait they wrote and
they published it way before
9 11 and said some will get an aircraft
that's crazy
yeah they they also mentioned and this
is just in the book
i did a podcast on kyle kingsbury um not
too long ago and he
i turned him onto the book and then he
hit me up i didn't even hear this part
he was like
in the very first chapter they mentioned
bill gates
eugenics and popular depopulation in the
same sentence
in in 90 seconds what yeah and and
or in the same paragraph there's one of
those two and i didn't even catch that
and then they
so they mentioned him a lot they
mentioned al gore a lot um
and so they they also give like what you
what you would call
a constellation like people born under
certain like
we would all be millennials i imagine
and so we're born during the unraveling
and we've only known unraveling in
crisis
i think i think he might be a it's
called like xenial
yeah generation y i was told growing up
no generation
not quite x like tail end of generation
x okay 79
was the year yeah so that was that that
would be till there was no crisis when i
was a kid it was beautiful roses it was
awesome
so you would be considered a nomad and i
would be we'd be considered
heroes uh i'm 38. so i was like right at
the beginning of it
and then uh people born in a crisis
period
period are called artists and then
people born during a high are called
prophets
and so they they go into a lot of detail
as to why they're named that
and and so they talk about the boomers
their role in this crisis
generation x in this crisis so they they
predicted
insurrection they predicted militias
portable weapons crashing a plane a lot
of this stuff
you know i will say we'd have to go into
the book and
i'll tell you this i didn't read the
book maybe they say here's a hundred
things that we think will happen and
then you just cherry-pick the seven
that are relevant to us go ah that
proves i'm right not really
so is it just like they threw a bunch of
darts at the wall and said we'll see
what happens and then
we're cherry-picking i'll tell you
exactly what it is because this
i was listening to it this morning
everything i said
i didn't really leave out anything if i
might have left out anything it would
have been one thing
and this is all in like two paragraphs
and so
they what they said was right afterwards
they were like
likely none of these things will
actually happen in this way
but the underlying tone will things like
this will happen
this will be the nature of things to
happen and so
there wasn't much other than this this
was like two paragraphs i just distilled
it down a little bit
right right you know so they and then
they went on to say like
in a crisis period if it if tensions
keep rising
and there is any spark of violence it
will likely lead to war so
i'm i'm trying to use their words as
much as possible if it does lead to war
it's likely to end in total war the
the enemy rendered nil um and
afterwards one society dies a new one is
born
and basically there's there's no way to
stop
a winter period from do they think that
the united states
is going to enter a new spring or in
that context what if china crushes the
united states and destroys our society
in that sense what they would say
because they they do say it is possible
for
the united states to be the the loser in
this and they're really
talking mainly eccentric around the u.s
so when they do talk about this they say
that no matter what the spring is also
coming
so spring will definitely come but
that's not really saying much for the
the losing side you know what's crazy
is that you go back 80 years what do you
got the end of world war ii
you go back 80 years before that what do
you got in the civil war
you go back 80 years before that what do
you got the revolution end of the
revolution these are all wars
crazy and what they say is every single
time if there's war
the most um powerful weapons of war
are definitely used there's there's no
way around it so you look back
you know the the um atomic bomb at the
end of world war
ii before that what was the most
powerful thing the gatling gun the
gatling gun i think was
1873 maybe okay my gun history good no
probably not
but uh they were using percussion
revolvers
i think they were man i don't know a lot
about guns but i'm sure a lot of people
are like i'm surprised you know those
things existed
uh they had these uh i'm pretty sure
they had percussion revolvers basically
you would load the charge like you know
what is it called muzzle load
but it's like you pour into the side of
the revolver and then you use a
percussion cap
on the back and then there were a couple
different models
uh really amazing technology for the
time i i'd say there was one
where had two triggers you pull one to
to rotate and pull the hammer and the
other to fire the hammer
and uh they're not particularly
convenient but it was like
it was uh i think it was the london
armory was it london arms company i
don't know a whole lot about this stuff
i should learn my gun history
and uh they were selling to the
confederate i think they were selling
the confederates
and so they're giving them these
percussion rifles so that was like
really revolutionary attack at the time
that you could carry around this loaded
you know i think they had what eight
shots maybe
and so coming from the muzzle loaded era
of just like you know stuffing the ball
and
through the muzzle and then firing and
then doing again all of a sudden these
guys had small arms where they could go
boom boom boom
so that's that was legitimate technology
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you